Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
C'è un palco più grosso
dell'Ariston, che figata.
Allora, mi hanno messo per prima,
così io devo un po' rompere il ghiaccio.
Sono contenta, ci sono tante donne
e anche tanti uomini tra l'altro.
Volevo raccontare, insomma,
quello che sono io,
che sono una donna, anche se non sembra
e sono contenta di essere una donna.
Solo ogni tanto vorrei essere un uomo
per farmi i complimenti
e dirmi: "Ciao, bella figa"
oppure per chiedermi:
"Cosa fai stasera, esci? Cosa fai?"
"No, sto a casa,
tolgo la pelle ai peperoni".
Prendermi questa soddisfazione:
"No, sto a casa
a purgare i colombi,
così domani mattina mi sveglio
e sembra che abbia nevicato".
No, sono contenta di essere una donna,
non ho mai avuto l'invidia del pene.
Nostalgia qualche volta,
qualche volta nostalgia,
ma invidia proprio mai.
È un bell'articolo, eh,
per carità, divertente quando vuole,
poi è mutevole, come il cielo d'Irlanda:
a volte è gnecco come i fondi di caffè,
a volte è nodoso
come il bastone degli alpini,
a volte è triste
come Mogol senza Battisti
e a volte è proprio fiero
come l'ultimo dei Moicani,
ma non mi interessa assolutamente.
Poi non mi piace neanche quando dicono:
"Ah, che brava che sei,
sei veramente una donna con le palle".
Ecco, a me quella roba lì,
non so a voi, ma a me
la donna con le palle
non mi piace, perché
io ho le tette,
mi bastano e mi avanzano,
tra l'altro sono due anche quelle
e non è un problema.
Io infatti non so come faccia
la Merkel, e anche la Camusso,
che sotto deve avere
un astuccio di bocce da sei.
Insomma, abbiamo le tette,
non abbiamo il martello
e abbiamo anche
il cervello un po' più piccolo
rispetto a quello degli uomini,
questo voi lo sapevate?
L'uomo ce l'ha più grosso - il cervello -
e pensa di essere più intelligente.
Ecco, no. Allora,
le cose sono andate così,
che quando il creatore
ha fatto l'uomo e la donna
li ha fatti con la quantità
di cervello uguale,
solo che mentre la donna andava, veniva,
beveva alle sorgenti,
schivava i dinosauri,
si riparava nelle caverne,
mangiava le bacche, l'uomo no.
L'uomo era un cretino,
l'uomo si attaccava
alle palle dei mammut,
sbatteva contro i rami bassi,
i serpenti li mangiava
direttamente dalla coda
e le bacche invece di metterle in bocca
le metteva nel retto pensando
di essere una slot machine.
Allora il creatore ah detto:
beh, allora aggiungiamogli
un po' più di cervello e
così gliene ha aggiunto
ancora un po'. A un certo punto
è scoppiato un temporale
e mentre la donna
si riparava dentro la caverna,
l'uomo è uscito fuori,
"Ah ah, che figo, è capodanno".
Allora lì il creatore ha capito
che non poteva
aggiungergliene dell'altro,
che doveva fare
con quello che c'era,
sennò doveva fargli
la testa lunga come Homer Simpson.
Ed ecco spiegato perché
l'uomo ha più cervello.
No, sono contenta di essere una donna,
di essere una donna anche di spettacolo,
perché ci sono anche
dei bellissimi modelli femminili
nel mondo dello spettacolo.
C'è la Chiabotto che beve l'acqua
ed elimina l'acqua,
che fa tanta plin plin.
La Marcuzzi che mangia il bifidus
e ritrova
la sua naturale regolarità,
fa tanta plon plon.
Speriamo che non facciamo mai
lo spot insieme,
perché sennò, plin plin
plon plon, il concerto,
dirige il maestro Vessicchio. (Applausi)
Quello che non mi piace è che spesso
nelle donne di spettacolo,
quelle che magari hanno anche
raggiunto il successo,
non si capisce come, per due doti credo,
quella davanti e quella dietro,
che quando sono intervistate
da questi giornalisti rispondono così.
Allora, il giornalista chiede:
"Come è arrivata al successo?"
"Ho fatto tanta gavetta".
Ecco. Allora, io volevo dire una cosa.
Ma ce ne fosse una, una di quelle lì,
perché non è che stiamo
tutte così, una parte è così
e l'altra... Una di quelle lì che dica:
"Come sono arrivata?
Sono rotolata da un lenzuolo all'altro
finché son caduta in quello giusto.
Come sono arrivata al successo?
L'ho data via".
Guarda che sarebbe veramente innovativo, altro che TED.
"L'ho data via,
l'ho data via "sans frontières",
l'ho data via, guarda, come il granturco
ai piccioni di piazza San Marco,
come le casse di minerale ai profughi.
L'hai presente l'ANAS
quando sparge il sale in inverno?
Così, senza neanche controllare,
c'è stato un traffico,
lì sotto, come nella piazzetta di Capri
a Ferragosto proprio.
Se c'era da darla una volta la davo
anche due per precauzione, guarda".
Oppure quando i giornalisti fanno
quelle belle domande del tipo:
"Ma qual è il tuo peggiore difetto?"
Perché i giornalisti
fanno delle domande...
E loro fanno la faccia della Gioconda
che ha preso la purga...
"Il mio peggior difetto? Mi piace leccare
lo zucchero a velo dei krapfen.
Il mio peggior difetto?
Credere ancora tanto nell'amicizia".
Ma capisci? Ma una, una
che dica: il mio peggior difetto?
Tiro, tiro di coca guarda, tiro di coca
che è un casino, guarda.
Scopo ammanettata a un dobermann
e mi faccio legare alla testiera
del letto coi fili dei freni della bici.
A pranzo, se non vedo il fondo
del bottiglione di vino da due litri
non son contenta e a Natale
mi vesto da chierichetta
e limono con mio zio
che è un diacono laico.
Bon. Una che dicesse così.
E c'è anche un altro momento in cui
la donna è particolarmente ipocrita,
è quando si rifà.
Adesso c'è la moda di rifarsi, no?
Ma non c'è nessuna che lo dice.
Anzi, al contrario.
E tu vedi: prima una aveva 50 anni,
dopo una settimana ne ha 30.
Ma è impossibile. Prima aveva
le borse di Louis Vuitton
sotto gli occhi, il giorno dopo
liscia, come un patin noir, proprio.
Prima era un velluto mille coste,
poi una padella antiaderente.
Aveva le palpebre tutte che ci voleva
l'avvolgibile per tirarle su,
il giorno dopo arriva
con i bulbi di Frankenstein.
E poi anche lì,
se il giornalista chiede:
"Qual è il segreto di questa
eterna giovinezza,
di questa pelle così fresca?"
E loro, invece di dire: Guarda,
mi sono fatta un po' di cose,
ialuronico... no...
"Il segreto di questa mia giovinezza,?
Di questa pelle così fresca?
Stile di vita sano e qualche integratore".
Ma vaffanculo, guarda. (Applausi)
Ma quale stile di vita sano?
Ma abbi pazienza, il giorno prima
avevi il naso come Depardieu,
a panino, a culetto di neonato,
il giorno dopo ce l'hai
tutto all'insù come la Tour Eiffel,
è lo stile di vita sano,
cos'è il gioco dell'oca
dove l'oca sono io?
Ce l'ho su scritto
sulla fronte umida "Giocondo"?
Oppure le labbra.
"E queste labbra bellissime?".
Guarda, queste labbra, che poi
non riescono neanche più
a parlare, sembrano dei cammelli.
"Queste labbra mangio
moltissimi grissini di crusca".
Sentito con le mie orecchie.
Ma come, fammi capire...
Ma anch'io faccio lo stile di vita sano,
eppure ho delle rughe
che sembro il canale di Panama.
Qua in mezzo, si forma
questa ruga qua in mezzo che è un
colpo di machete, praticamente.
Ce lo abbiamo tantissimo io, la Fornero
e poi ho notato, l'altra domenica,
Ligabue, ce l'ha anche lui, è vero.
Sì, è incredibile, però è così.
Oppure si rifanno le tette.
Il giorno prima sono
praticamente piatte, piatte,
dei vassoi praticamente.
Si possono faxare.
Cosa fai, prendi l'aereo?
No, no, vado via fax.
E il giorno dopo le tette
gonfiate con l'elio.
Ma una volta dire la verità,
la verità normale, dire sì,
mi sono fatta un po'
di ialuronico, mi sono sbotulata,
mi facevo cagare e quindi
ho trovato questa soluzione.
No, perché poi dicono
alle donne: ma l'importante
non è essere belle fuori
ma essere belle dentro.
Ma quando mai, dentro dove?
Nel colon?
No, è anche importante
essere belle fuori.
Per i maschi è più semplice,
per le donne no.
Io ogni tanto vorrei svegliarmi
la mattina e avere,
non so, il culo di Penelope Cruz,
il corpo di Cameron Diaz
e le tette della Cucinotta
e invece poi mi guardo e c'ho
il culo, così, di Bruno Vespa,
il corpo di Mentana
e le tette di Giacobbo.
Poi dicono ma no,
ma non è importante essere belle.
Allora, chiariamo, è importante
essere belle, è una cosa figa,
chi ha quella dota lì
la deve sfruttare, è una comodità,
ma in tante piccole cose.
Per esempio, se tu buchi
la ruota della macchina,
se sei bella torni a casa
anche con le mani pulite;
se sei brutta no, ti devi lordare tu.
Se caschi per la strada,
se sei bella qualcuno ti tira su,
se sei brutta ti fanno il video
e lo mettono su Youtube.
Capito? (Applausi) No, bisogna
essere fighi, ecco, non belli,
fighi, fighi, cioè, riuscire
a fare quello che si vuole,
a spremersi, a tirar fuori...
cioè, a scoprire
quali sono le lampadine
che abbiamo dentro e accenderle.
Non è semplicissimo,
ma è quello che dobbiamo fare.
E dobbiamo fare i conti
anche con il nostro passato,
in fondo noi abbiamo fatto
tanta strada, no,
dobbiamo essere delle bravi mogli,
delle brave compagne,
delle brave amiche, delle brave madri.
Una volta dovevamo anche
arrivare vergini al matrimonio,
con la iolanda ancora nel cellophane.
Fallo adesso...
Per fortuna non è più così,
però alcune donne ancora
ci tengono ed è una scelta,
che rende il compito di noi
dispensatrici più oneroso
e ricco di impegni, però va benissimo.
Io lo dico a quelle che, insomma, ancora
non hanno - non credo
perché vedendovi... -
però conservarla non paga secondo me,
perché è come quando
metti i soldi in banca,
come i BOT: lasci lì e poi alla fine
quanto ti danno di interesse, "0,...",
non vale, dopo un po' si deprezza,
scade, come la lira,
non è come una bottiglia di Barbera
che la metti lì e due o tre anni dopo
la scaraffi
ed è una goduria,
o la toma che col tempo...
è un po' come il tartufo,
che lo lasci lì
e dopo un po' se non lo mangi...
E poi anche per gli uomini,
dico, che soddisfazione c'è
a fare l'amore per la prima volta
con una donna
che non ha mai
fatto l'amore, con una vergine,
è una fatica, come quelli che hanno dato
il primo colpo di piccone
per fare il tunnel del Monte Bianco.
Cioè chi se la gode di più,
quelli che scavano il tunnel
o quelli che ci vanno avanti e indietro
a sciare a Chamonix?
No, per dire... È complicato,
è anche faticoso.
Chi è che ha fatto meno fatica,
quello che percorre
il sentiero che è già segnato da altri.
Fare l'amore con una donna
per la prima volta
è un po' come andare alla Rinascente
in tempo di saldi:
si sta stretti e ti senti soffocare.
Però le donne fanno ancora fatica,
soprattutto quando...
mi sembra di avere Fazio,
devo proprio finire...
non posso andare avanti...
No, allora devo finire.
Taglio tutto, vado avanti.
Volevo dire due cose ancora.
Una cosa che mi diceva sempre mia nonna,
che quando me lo diceva dicevo:
"Ma nonna ma cosa mi insegni,
che cosa orribile"
ed è questa, che per far durare
una coppia, diceva,
"per far durare un matrimonio
bisogna mordere l'aglio
e dire che è dolce".
E io dicevo,
ma che insegnamento orripilante nonna.
E invece col passare del tempo,
io adesso ho 49 anni
e sto insieme a un balengo da una vita,
mi sono accorta che è proprio così,
che ogni tanto per far durare le coppie,
non solo le coppie sentimentali
ma anche le coppie di lavoro,
bisogna mordere l'aglio,
lasciare che passi la bufera
e non star lì sempre
a rompere le scatole,
perché ogni fuoco, come dicono
i napoletani, cenere diventa.
L'altra cosa - e me lo dice
la mia amica Ida
che è vecchia come la penicillina -
dice che non bisogna mai
lasciarsi sfuggire le occasioni,
perché poi il tempo passa
e non sei più in tempo,
ti viene poi il culo secco
come un cantuccio
e non te ne puoi fare più niente
e che nell'amore
bisogna anche un po' accontentarsi,
che non vuol dire rassegnarsi:
accontentarsi.
E che agli uomini - mi dice lei -
dopo una certa età
non viene più duro niente,
tranne l'aorta.
E da ultimo volevo raccontare una cosa
che era successa un po' di tempo fa,
a "Che tempo che fa". Erano
venuti ospiti Dario Fo e Franca Rame.
e mi ricordo che Franca Rame
disse una cosa bellissima.
Disse: "Io non so
se morirò prima di Dario.
Quello che so è che farò
scrivere sulla sua tomba
questa frase: Com'era vivo da vivo"
e io volevo augurarlo a tutti voi,
di essere vivi da vivi.
(Applausi)